it seems like whenever my creative
burnout is at an all-time high and I
wonder if I finally run out of ideas
another trailer comes out that gives me
55 new things to say thank God for the
weird Sony venom verse for always
getting me out of a slump by being so
itself [ __ ] I was so frustrated trying
to write an x-men legends review that I
almost quit YouTube the same morning
Morbius the living vampire graced us
with his clownish presence
remember that cut alternate ending for
blade see that Morbius and a mask well
turns out he was Jared Leto who would
have thought and he's actually Jason
Todd Morbius the living vampire is a
vile vampiric villain in sometimes
antihero that's known for occasionally
battling six-armed spider-man you may
recognize him from the most skippable
episodes of spider-man the animated
series and that one time he found a pile
of Punishers limbs and sewed them back
together to make a Franken castle he
just recently got a teaser for his new
solo movie that caught everyone off
guard by being an MCU movie and with
that I want to discuss why Morbius is
going to complicate things for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe going forward
but first let's discuss the content of
the trailer itself this feels like an
unreleased movie from the mid-2000s it
has the same color palette and some
parts of it even remind me of daredevil
given how every Marvel movie lately has
been so tied to the infinity saga and
the Avengers I'm happy to see something
that isn't really concerned with any of
that and just wants to tell a
disconnected story with a different tone
it's refreshing and worrying at the same
time much like well every movie Sony is
working on the film stars actual creepy
vampire Jared Leto in the title role of
Michael Morbius a sad scientist man with
a rare blood disease who wants to cure
himself with some fringe science methods
that involve probably splicing himself
with bat DNA unlike all other vampires
in the Marvel Universe Morbius the
living vampire is special and that he's
not magic or anything
his powers come entirely from science
which is why he wants so much
we see lots of scenes of him doing all
the hallmarks of a classic mm superhero
movie suddenly getting shredded abs with
your powers a scene of him testing him
out in a big empty lab staring at a
tunnel full of swarming bats rising and
him killing dozens of armed soldiers and
black outfits and I guess doing some
Nightcrawler stuff for a teaser trailer
this sure showed a lot more than the
other one they had for venom remember
that they didn't have any of the CGI
done so they just showed empty shots
without it and everyone started
speculating venom would be in like one
scene I appreciate that this one feels a
little less rushed and undercooked but
it bothers me that so much of the
imagery feels like scenes lifted from
other more successful movies then again
that could always be chalked up to Sony
just wanting to cut their trailers
together with the most recognizable and
marketable elements which brings us to
the part of the movie that may start
complicating things I I could make a
Batman and Joker bit right now but like
I only see Batman in the scene talking
to Jared Leto and white makeup
Joaquin Phoenix is over here getting
nominated for an Oscar in every damn
category so Jared Leto fires back with
his new sad rebound date that completely
fails to make his ex jealous and also
spider-man movie references it's
abundantly clear what Sony had to gain
from losing their [ __ ] and holding
spider-man for ransom earlier this year
while Tom had to play hostage negotiator
between the two giant greedy
corporations who are equally at fault
they bullied their way into being able
to make unlicensed fanfiction and then
say it's canon canon is a very highly
emphasized part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and they take great pains to
meticulously plan out every little
detail so the timeline and connective
bits always makes sense but now he got
Sony over here just shoving random
movies in places and muddying up the
whole thing this venom take place at
some point during the five years after
thinness made everyone disappear is it
before what had waited when did that
happen what's going on
frankly I don't really care anymore as
long as the movies are good continuity
errors can be irritating but if the
story and characters are good enough you
can look past it
and even if this turns out to be
complete crap I'm glad it happened
because we got to see what happened to
the vulture because he's my favorite of
the MCU Spidey villains spider-man Home
Coming set up so many future plans with
him and scorpion and then like like they
completely forgot about them
I keep seeing all these proposals for
the villain for spider-man home wrecker
3 and none of them are a winged GUID 2
mr. mom Abed if Sony hadn't pulled that
stunt he'd end up like Justin Hammer or
fake Mandarin exiled to the land of five
minutes short films or references and
agents of shield from this scene we can
tell he's breaking out of jail given the
uniform and he has some kind of prior
relationship with Morbius the living
plasma vampire given Sony's track record
I wouldn't be surprised if this was the
final scene in the movie or the
post-credits scene they do that all the
time with their ads since this guy and
far from home is probably the chameleon
we now have enough dudes to be the
sinister six-pack I know Sony's been
betting on that horse forever
in like a really sad shameful way where
the horse has been put down for
trampling a picnic full of orphans but
they're so desperate to pay off these
gambling debts they've deluded
themselves into believing the horse will
come back with Tobey Maguire riding it
to Victory within the bowels of the MCU
grows a strange parasitic twin feeding
on its life force to sustain itself
while only further complicating its
continuity which is ironic considering
the sub universe consists of a site and
a blood sucking vampire
I feel like this secondary MCU will be
mostly comprised of offshoots and
spin-offs from Tom Spidey's mainline
adventures I wouldn't be shocked to see
if Mysterio came back in one of these at
some point but that begs the question
that has everyone so stumped is this
crossover only one way can Morbius the
plasma mane and venom affect the events
of Marvel movies with Captain Marvel or
black panther or Doctor Strange my gut
wants to say no but Sony was very
adamant that spider-man can appear in
their stuff and the MCU to bridge both
series and anything those characters say
or do to him could absolutely have an
effect on his solo movies
forward I've even heard talk that he's
going to appear in venom two and you
can't just randomly have Spidey go to
San Francisco and fight carnage without
that affecting anything maybe he's
hiding there while he's on the run from
the law considering he's a fugitive as
implied by this poster here and that's
that uh that's not the right spider-man
boss alright can we talk about the
poster let's talk about the poster I
don't agree with the theorists
speculating this is connecting Morbius
to the Raimi spider-man universe or
saying Tobey Maguire is coming back it's
just lazy work from the set dressers all
we need a poster of spider-man you're
supposed to respite easy-peasy I
realized the hilarious problem
spider-man ps4s hyper-realistic
graphical style has created by offering
an endless list of possibilities for
spider-man poses that are good enough to
use against something live-action
graphic designers and prop departments
are now and maybe forever going to just
use that instead of getting proper
photos of Tom in the suit doing a
swinging pose because it's faster and
cheaper it wouldn't be so glaring and
annoying if the same type of thing
hadn't happened multiple times in this
last year like this magazine cover is
pretty cool otherwise and I dig the
reference but come on if you're going to
insist on using a CGI model for
everything then why not just like boot
up Maya
grab the model put it in a handful of
sweet'n poses and hit render y'all need
to hassle Tom to wear it every time
which they seem opposed to doing even
when their film is that too much work
yes alright then let's cut some corners
I know a neat trick so like in a free
update they added this to the game and
you don't even need to unlock it you get
it right away
you just pick in the menu jump off
something tall pause it go to the photo
mode and then boom there you go at least
it's the right goddamn costume now
thanks to the guy who did that edit by
the way I've also heard speculation that
Sony doesn't have the rights to the
costume which is even more confusing
since they have the rights to use the
character is Tom going to be wearing
some kind of Sony approved non stark
tech costume for appearances with these
bozos and then throw on the red and
black when he's hanging out with the
Avengers
I'd be kind of cool actually uh-oh maybe
give him an excuse to finally sew
together his own proper costume that's
not a billion-dollar skin-tight Ironman
suit made of nanomachines Sun or just
like to throw the last stand' suit on if
you want to be lazy I don't know even
this dumb Easter Egg in the background
raises so many questions
everything's been jumbled up and
confused by this movie and retroactively
lead by venom I've seen some people say
this is the beginning of the end for the
MCU but to me the MCU ended when Tony
Stark snapped his fingers that whole
story was built around him for ten years
and we saw the finale of everything they
were building up to now we're in
uncharted territory where the direction
is unclear projects are being greenlit
left and right this seems like the new
lineup is totally random it's in
complete chaos like I said in my video
speculating on venom it's nice to have
some variety because you always know
exactly what you're going to get with
the MCU
I appreciate weird random outliers like
this and I you know since Fox can't make
them anymore we got take what we can get
I mean what else is there you got a
blood shot I guess although if I'm being
totally honest part of me doesn't want
to see this if only for the sole reason
that his stars Jared Leto now he's a
fine actor and I thought he was good and
Blade Runner that time Batman acts
murdered him but behind the scenes he's
kind of a jackass and some speculate
maybe a little creepy - then again some
singing part of me wonders if every
Hollywood actor is actually a drug
kingpin or a sexual predator or just an
annoying dick in which case it's hard to
have such high standards because then
you can only see like three movies a
year if you're only going to ones with
the cast that are like 100% not awful I
don't know yet I haven't decided if I'll
watch it but at least we're getting
something different at all
maybe complicating the MCU is exactly
what it needs right now
Marvel Studios are having to rely on a
lot less popular characters now to carry
the franchise since they retired their
biggest ones and they're scrambling and
to start up new projects in hopes that
it'll keep people interested in the hype
train or runnin if they just keep making
stuff we've already seen in the past
five years they run the risk of boring
the audience because it's the same thing
over and over
Morbius looks like a bizarro mishmash of
a million things and with a little luck
that'll make it feel unique by being
such a strange combination of other
movies maybe throwing Morbius and venom
into the mix will create a new
subcategory of Marvel films that are
darker and more street level with Spidey
being the connecting element that links
that universe to the big bright and
poppy Avengers films this is what I
wanted Spidey to do for the Netflix
Marvel shows before those were sliced
off and quarantined like a zombified
limb I for one welcome the change
because you know change is good even if
it's not always for the better we can
learn from that change and improve in
the future whether plasma man over here
is a mistake or not I think it'll be
interesting nonetheless and the state of
Marvel movies can definitely use it as a
springboard for bigger and better things
[Music]
[Music]